you know one thing you mentioned was
just the human nature
um and how we're wired for the seasons
how we're wired for quarterly in some
way
uh or in these short sprints maybe you
could unpack that a little bit in terms
of what you've learned about
human nature and work in relation to
this framework that's right so
everything we've talked about is on a
quarterly cycle
you know quarters are seasons you know
humans are wired for seasons i think
there's fundamentally something very
organic about this way of working
so let me kind of snap it all together
okay so
you're going to have a fiscal year you
know it's an accounting concept but
you're going to use it
to generate your reporting the finance
team will
and your sales teams are going to be on
quarterly sales plans or snap to those
fiscal quarters so
you know let's assume that q1 is now
gonna be february march april
and just to be clear when you say fiscal
versus calendar
right fiscal just means how the finance
department defines
three months a year four years that's
how it that's right when you say
calendar it just means the calendar
because people get caught up on what is
the fiscal year
right that's all it means is that you
know which which months are we going to
use in q1
so let's assume that we use we say q1 is
february march april so that means that
the quarterly close is going to be in
april
and the sales kickoff is going to be in
february now what i would do with the
launch event is slotted in march
so this is the offset and for the simple
reason that you don't want to set
everybody's hair on fire at the same
time you don't want
the the sort of product marketing cycle
which revolves around this launch event
to be peaking at the same time that the
sales finance team
is sort of on that they're hitting their
kind of you being the founder in this
because the founders attention is also
important
it is exhausting as a founder to have to
do
you know three two hour meetings
with four departments that's right
and that's 12 hours so if you're doing
it
you know on this cadence yeah you know
the sales team's off
they're in their pipeline review and
optimization and check
but we're getting ready for the launch
of the new product right right exactly
so
so what ends up happening is under the
system when you snap it all together
month one of the quarter is very
dominated by planning you've got this
idea of sales kickoff
i would also always do my board meetings
in that first month of the quarter
right after for the finance team closes
the books so that's
in the previous quarter that's right 18
days i would always do it in the second
or third week of the quarter
why because the data is still fresh you
want the
the board to look at the freshest sales
data as soon as it gets reported out
that makes total sense right and then on
the heels of that board meeting you're
going to
you're going to basically um you're
going to
re-prioritize your overall product
roadmap so you're going to take those
strategic insights
that you just had to board me you're
going to re-prioritize the road map not
for the current quarter
because your launch event's about to be
in a few weeks but for the following
quarter
okay so that's month one is dominated by
the idea of planning then you go to
month two month two is dominated by the
idea of this launch event
right so the first couple of weeks of
the course of the month
month two the either you're finalizing
the event details you're finalizing the
marketing collateral
you're finalizing the presentations
there's a lot of work that goes into
that
it's you know marketing centric work and
then on the heels
of that launch event and say the second
or third
week of month two right in the middle of
the quarter you're gonna do a lot of
debriefing you know you just had this
big launch
how did it go you're gonna take all the
customer learning so you just got
through all those conversations
and you're gonna you know feed them back
into the company and internalize that
okay and then month three is and then
you know and then immediately right
after that um that launch event
the engineering team is going to start
working on the next quarter's release
right right
so month three is this very heads down
period in the company
where the engineers are focused on
coding and the sales people
are focused on closing and it's this
it's basically you know
it's it's closed it's uh it's a time for
it it's quite time
no distractions uh on the not right now
list etc